c'est l'heure de l'invité de paris
direct
et ce matin notre invité l'anthropologue
et écrivaine maggie paxon bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous mêmes par
visioconférence à l' isolement à
distance donc on va vous voir à l'image
l'espère anthropologue voilà je vous
entends en tout cas je vous vois pas
mais on va vous retrouver je l'espère
voilà c'est mieux comme ça vous êtes
anthropologue américaine gilles est
chargé de recherche à l'université
georgetown mais aussi à united states
holocaust memorial museum le musée du
mémorial de l'holocauste aux états unis
vos travaux ont notamment porté sur la
résistance les résistances plus tôt et
puis un vaste très vaste sujet très
abordé en ce moment la paix en 2019 vous
avez publié un livre intitulé de plateau
il vient de sortir traduit en français
sous un autre titre qui évoque
saint-exupéry on ne voit bien qu'avec le
coeur aux éditions payot c'est un
ouvrage consacré au destin d'un homme
daniel troc mais c'est l'un de vos
ancêtres il a dirigé une institution qui
rentrait dans l'histoire de france un
foyer pour jeunes enfants au chambon sur
lignon dans le centre de la france entre
la haute loire et et l'ardèche et il a
permis ainsi de sauver des milliers
d'enfants juifs entre 41 et 41 et 43
ce livre est votre recherche sur la vie
de cet homme pourquoi l'avoir écrit
comment vous est venue l'idée de ce
livre
dont j'avais l'idée que comme intro
pollock j'avais passé je vais j'avais
fait en recherche en russie pendant des
années j'ai fait marrer chances de
doctorat en fait en russie et après
avoir fait la recharge j'ai écrit le
doctorat et j'écris un livre
et me semblait que je veux les écouter
des questions un peu plus grand qu'avant
un peu plus large il me semblait que là
où le monde est maintenant on a besoin
de questions sauvé des trucs de base en
fait qu'est ce qu'il faut faire pour
avoir des sociétés kiki que qui peuvent
protéger des grenats la vénérable qui
comprennent quelque chose sur le fait
des hommes et j'ai trouvé un
mais il y avait à l'histoire de ma
famille en fait c'était l'histoire de la
femme le frère de la femme de mon
arrière-grand-père c'était daniel râpé
qui est un jeune homme au chambon sur
lignon de la prend dans la gare et son
histoire c'est à 104,10 ont été
extraordinaires il est venu au chambon
sur lignon pendant la guerre et la
protège et plein plein d'enfants et
ça m'a beaucoup inspiré qu'est-ce qu'il
a fait des moments où ils avaient besoin
de décider quoi de faire dessus protégé
au protéger protéger des autres l'a
décidé de protéger des autres est pour
lui c'était un moment très important a
finalement été arrêté elle est allée au
présent à moulins puis à compiègne puis
à buchenwald puis et les morts
finalement à maidanek donc sa vie était
très très intéressant et très
émouvante ces décisions à faire des
choses du bon pour pour des autres et
donc c'est ça rigolait il s'est donc
rendu dans ce village du
chambon-sur-lignon où là bas en gros
pour résumer ceux qui ne connaissent pas
cette histoire c'est tout un territoire
a fait le choix de de protéger les plus
faibles en pleine occupation allemande
il fallait beaucoup de courage dans un
village en grande partie protestants qui
avaient gardé une certaine philosophie
de toutes les persécutions qu'ont subis
les protestants pendant des siècles
cette tradition d'accueil d'ailleurs on
le voit dans votre livre elle perdure
aujourd'hui avec des migrants c'est ça
qui vous a touché notamment ce lien
entre le passé le présent au chambon sur
lignon
c'est ça je peux moi mon travail vente
c'était sur la mémoire à sociale donc
comment le passé disons et présente
maintenant donc je sais que il faut que
j'ai compris qu'un cochon bon il ya
toute une histoire de
des moments ont déjà quand les gens
protéger d d d d autres vulnérables a
donc elle le fait que ça continue
aujourd'hui c'était pour moi
extraordinaire il est un cada au chambon
sur lignon maintenant dans le plateau où
il ya des demandeurs d'asile qui vient
de partout à du monde et moi comme
entrepreneur une fois que j'ai compris
qu'il y a des gens un peu de partout
pour moi c'était un autre niveau de
l'histoire et moi je garde russe et il y
avait il y en avait des gens de la
russie où le caucase du sud où des gens
par les russes qui ne parlait pas
français donc je pouvais aussi
aider un peu et ça changeait aussi le
dynamique dans le livre parce que je
boycotte
c'est comme un endroit comme ça des gens
savent comment faire des bonnes choses
ça attire et on veut aider aussi
le fil rouge par
le fil rouge de ce livre c'est donc
votre quête à la fois sur l'histoire de
cet ancêtre et puis et puis sur votre
quête personnelle aussi donc on suit
votre parcours au chambon-sur-lignon en
suit le parcours de dénis trocmé durant
l'occupation
dans une lettre à ses parents 41 ai dit
qu'en aidant ses enfants il veut
contribuer à reconstruire le monde il
dit je n'avais pas envie d'avoir honte
de moi plusieurs phases de votre livre
commence d'ailleurs par une
interpellation au lecteur si vous aviez
vécu à cette époque on vit justement une
période troublée vous connaissez bien la
russie vous connaissez bien l'ukraine
est ce que vous pensez que des russes et
des ukrainiens se posent les mêmes
questions aujourd'hui j'ai peur d'avoir
honte de moi il faut que j'agisse
mais je suis sûr qu'il y en ait un des
russes et des ukrainiens qui se posent
la même question je suis aussi sûr que
les russes et les ukrainiens
parmi eux il ya des gens qui veulent
avoir la paix je suis sur elle des gens
qui comprennent que ces pages leur
identité c'est pas juste une identité
nationale mais un identité humaine et
anil sont pas justes et des sucres les
russes sont des armes d âme et je suis
sûr qu'il y en a qui comprennent ça et
je suis sûr qu'il ya dans le monde
entier des gens qui peuvent comprendre a
essaimé des gens jeunes qui sont même si
leur pays sont en guerre il peut s'aimer
maggie paxon justement vous avez vécu
pendant 15 ans en russie vous avez fait
un doctorat là bas et vous est notamment
intéressé aux toutes petites communautés
du nord la russie vous avez vécu dans la
russie profonde
quelle est l'opinion des russes ruraux
et des russes des petites villes
vis-à-vis du kremlin en général parce
qu'on parle beaucoup de moscou et saint
pétersbourg mais très peu de est ce
qu'il ya une notion de défiance
vis-à-vis du pouvoir
oui mais je travaille beaucoup sur ça
quand j'étais là mais ça fait un bout de
temps et ça je moi je
ça fait dix ans plus que dix ans que je
suis plus là
mais je pourrais dire que des gens qui
sont là
sont les gens comme tous les autres il
pensait
avoir des choses qu'ils qui veulent
comprendre qui est qui qui qui qui sont
importants pour en même temps de jeu
c'est un peu compliqué mais je pense que
le message de leur gouvernement peut
raisonner avec dix ont un moment donné 1
il ya des questions de la deuxième
guerre mondiale qui sont pour important
pour important les questions de
l'économie maintenant et c'est difficile
d'avoir d'autres voies d'information si
on est loin donc quand j'étais là j'ai
passé beaucoup d'hommes je regardais
comment et voyez le pouvoir est il pour
eux c'était important d'avoir quelqu'un
qui était fort
un leader qui était fort et donc je ne
sais pas je ne suis pas sûr mais je
c'est possible c'est bien parce que ça
résonne avec
et mais je sais aussi que moi comme
américaine et peuvent aimer mais ils
pouvaient s'ouvrir pour moi même quand
il n'est pas sur des états unis de là
relation avec des états unis donc
gg je connais des gens qui étaient très
sensible très intelligente et qu'ils
aient été capables de comprendre un
comment aimer les autres merci beaucoup
maggie paxon on voit bien qu'avec le
coeur c'est le titre de votre livre
c'est un extrait de saint-exupéry qui
revient souvent dans le récit 1 voix
aplec le petit prince a été publié
précisément 43 au moment du basculement
de la vie de nombreux français dont
daniel trocmé le meilleur de l'homme
peut aussi sortir des crises c'est un
peu en résumé ce qu'on pourrait retenir
de ce livre sorti doko aux éditions
payot qui vient d'être traduit en
français merci d'avoir été notre invité
ce matin merci et merci à vous d'avoir
choisi france 24 on se retrouve dans
moins de cinq minutes pour un nouveau
point notamment sur l'actualité en
ukraine a tout de suite
[Musique]